Falls are about the sixth or seventh
leading cause of death in this country
and this is a very critical area of
research because it is so common and it so
often results in serious injury. One of
the exciting interventions that we are
studying is Tai Chi for its effect on
balance and mobility. We introduced
Tai Chi in our housing facilities, did a
12-week intervention in which they
practiced Tai Chi for two days out of
every week and compared their function
at the end of this 12 weeks to a group
of people who just sat in educational
classes. And lo and behold, Tai Chi not
only improved gait and balance, but
improved their overall functional ability.
I found the benefits for Tai Chi for me
was relaxation, lowering my blood
pressure for sure. The movements are slow,
it keeps me mindful of what I'm doing
all the time and it helps your
thinking, I feel.
So we want to improve
the brain's ability to adapt to our
local environment and we're doing that
many different ways, but one of the most
exciting areas I think is electrical
stimulation of the brain. It doesn't hurt,
it's as though you've taken a little
small battery and you've applied it to
the forehead. This electrical stimulation
can have great impact on mobility, on
balance, on the ability to think and to
do two tasks at the same time, so that
someday I'll be sitting at this desk
feeling tired, perhaps after a meal, and
all I have to do is just attach a little
battery to my forehead to get a boost.